OLIN LAN: Hello, everybody.
I'm Oli Lan, an engineer
on the Android Wear team.
TONY FERREIRA: And
I'm Tony Ferreira,
a designer on Android Wear.
OLIN LAN: It's great to be here.
We're really excited to tell
you about the new stuff coming
to watch faces on Android Wear.
The watch face is at the heart
of the Android Wear interface.
Of course, it tells the time.
And with the thousands of
watch faces on Google Play,
it's a great way for users
to express their style.
We added interactivity
last year,
and the watch face came
to life like never before.
But the watch face can do more.
As an always-on screen
that's just a glance away,
it's a great place to get the
information you care about.
And that's why we're
introducing the Complications
API for Android Wear.
TONY FERREIRA: But first of
all, what are Complications?
That term comes from
traditional watchmaking.
And it means, well,
pretty much anything
that's not telling the time.
Complications on
mechanical watches
show things like the date, your
alarm, or phase of the moon.
So the small dials
you see on this watch,
they are complications.
On smartwatches there
are new possibilities,
like the weather, stock prices,
or events from your calendar.
OLIN LAN: Many watch
faces on Android Wear
already include complications,
like Bits from usTwo or Legacy
from Zuhanden.
But as it stands,
each watch face
has to go and get
the data itself.
That could mean
your watch face has
to find its own source
of weather data,
or finance data, or anything
else you want to show.
And if the user wants to see
something you haven't included,
they're out of luck.
Or maybe you're not a
watch face developer,
but your app has data that would
be great on the watch face,
like fitness stats
or finance info.
As it stands, there's
no way to do this other
than building your
own watch face
or making deals with individual
watch face developers.
The Complications
API for Android Wear
changes all of this.
Apps using the API will be
data providers or watch faces.
If you build a watch face
using the Complications API,
then you get access to a whole
ecosystem of data providers.
Here are just some of the
partners already working
on using the API.
And if you build
a data provider,
you can get your data on a
whole range of watch faces.
Now on Google Play,
there's a huge range
of styles of watch faces.
So there's no way
that just one style,
one visual style of complication
would fit on every watch face.
Because of that, with
the Complications API,
the watch face gets to decide
how to render the data.
It gets to choose the visual
style, the colors, the fonts,
etc.
The data provided just
provides raw fields
like strings, text,
images, and numbers.
Before we get into the
details of the API though,
Tony is going to go
through some things
to think about when
designing for complications.
TONY FERREIRA: Thanks, Oli.
So some of you may have already
checked out the Material design
spec for wearables.
And there you'll find
a ton of useful things
to help developers and designers
design for Android Wear.
I'd like to highlight
some of the things, some
of those design principles
that you'll find in there
and how they apply
to complications.
So the first design
principle is glanceable,
making things clear
and understandable.
For complications, small, easy
to read snippets of information
work best.
It's very important that the
information on the watch face
is organized with a clear
hierarchy, large enough
to read easily, and
high enough in contrast.
Users shouldn't need to
squint to read the UI.
The second design
principle is time saving,
getting the information you want
quickly without any roadblocks.
Instead of navigating
to your favorite apps
to find the
information you want,
with the introduction
of complications,
it's right there
on the watch face.
Complications are also tapable.
So you can deep link to your
favorite contact or upcoming
calendar event.
And complications
are also persistent,
there whenever you need them.
The third design
principle is consistent.
Complications should have
a healthy relationship
with the watch face.
As Oli just said, with
Complications on Android Wear,
the watch face decides how the
complications are rendered.
So they feel part
of the same family.
Consider aligning the
style of the complications
with the watch face.
Oli is now going to talk you
through the complication types.
OLIN LAN: Thanks, Tony.
So complications are all about
data, supplied by provider apps
and displayed on watch faces.
This could include numerical
data like your battery level,
text like the title
of your next meeting,
or images like an
icon or a profile pic.
Not every type of data will
fit on every watch face.
There might only be
space for a small icon
or a short bit of text.
Or you might want to use
numerical data without having
to show text or images.
So watch faces need to
say what they can display.
And data providers need to
say what they can supply.
To help with this, we've defined
a number of complication types.
Complication types
determine what kinds of data
are included.
There's usually one field that's
the key piece of information.
And we've named the
types after that field.
So here you see examples
of the short text type.
These are all short
text complications.
But as you can see there
are optional elements.
There may be an icon
or a second string.
But the most important value
is contained in the short text
field.
If you're a data
provider, you can
choose which of the
optional fields to include.
But a short text
complication must always
include the short text field.
If you're building a watch face
and you support short text,
you need to consider
all of these variations.
Here are some other examples.
You might not need any text
to convey the information.
Then maybe the icon
type is enough.
Or, if you have numerical
data within bounds
like a percentage, then
the range value type
could be for you.
We also have a few other types.
You'll notice that we have
bot icon and small image.
The difference is that
images for the icon field
should be tintable
by the watch face.
They should be single color
with a transparent background.
This allows the watch face to
fit it better to its style.
So if you are building a
watch face where full color
images won't match
the style, then you
can support the icon type.
But you might not want to
support the small image type,
where images may be full color.
So when you're thinking about
the different complication
types, if you are
building a provider,
think about the different
forms your data can take.
And if you're
building complications
into a watch face, think
about how many of the types
you want to support.
Now back to Tony to talk about
some more guidelines for what
face developers.
TONY FERREIRA: OK, so I
want to talk a little bit
about the things
you should consider
when designing complications.
However, bear in mind
there isn't a one size
fits all solution to this.
We have a diverse collection
of watch faces on the platform.
And we think it's important
that complications
are flexible enough to
mirror that diversity.
So please use these guidelines
as a starting point.
But if you feel your
watch face would benefit
from deviating from these
guidelines, then by all means
please do so.
Complication should never
conflict with the surrounding
objects on the watch face.
For more traditional watch
face layouts, as shown here,
these red areas, in general,
shouldn't have complications.
As it will be a conflict with
other parts of the watch face.
Give your complications
a bit of space,
so they have room
to breathe as well.
And if possible, staying true to
the alignment of the watch face
will also help you
achieve better balance.
So if you have a
center aligned clock,
it might make sense to center
align the complications
as well.
Complications can be
rendered however you wish.
Though you might want
to give your data
a little more protection and
house them in a container.
So we found these
form factors work well
with the various data types.
We have circle, square,
pill, and rectangle.
And bear in mind, the size
and form of these containers
decide what data types
can and can't be rendered.
And containers are optional.
Sometimes they help.
Sometimes they don't.
But the important thing to
remember, as a watch face
developer, is you have
the freedom to choose.
Building a strong relationship
with the watch face
is also very important.
You don't want
your complications
to seem like an afterthought.
So here are some
things to consider.
Use color to tint the data.
This will help create better
harmony with the watch face.
Decide whether your
complications need containers
or not.
You can see in this
example, in the middle,
we've removed the
containers just
to help the complications better
integrate into the watch face.
And play around with scale.
This will help you achieve
better visual hierarchy.
But most importantly,
on top of all that,
just have fun with them.
And don't be scared
to get creative.
You can have multiple
complications on a watch face.
This is awesome
for those of us who
want to surface lots of data.
Here you can see we've
removed the containers
to create more space.
And we can easily fit
eight complications
on a single watch face.
If multiple complications is a
direction you wish to go down,
just try to make sure that
things don't get too cluttered
and the UI remains glanceable.
The Complications API can also
be used as a creative tool.
With the ranged
value data type, you
can abstract that data
whichever way you like.
So in the example,
we've shown here,
we display your step count goal.
Throughout the day,
as you get closer
to reaching your
step count goal,
the graphic in the
background also updates.
Presenting the
data like this, in
an unconventional
and abstract way,
opens the door for more fun
and engaging watch faces.
And just to finish,
here are a few examples
of implemented
complications designed
by our creative partners usTwo.
In the first example
here, you can
see they've kept things simple
and find a straightforward way
of adding complications to
a preexisting watch face,
removing containers
and tinting the data.
The second example is
a little more bespoke.
They've used their
creative license
and played around with things
like the layout and the form
factors.
This helps better
align the complications
with the watch face aesthetic.
In the last example, we have had
some fun with the range value
data type, creating a really
cool generative abstract
design.
In this example, you can
imagine your daily step count
or battery level
being represented.
I'll now hand you
over to Oli, who
is going to talk you through
the details of the API.
OLIN LAN: Thanks, Tony.
OK, so let's take a look at
how this all fits together.
Android Wear manages the flow
of data between data providers
and watch faces.
When data is needed
for a complication,
Android Wear will
send an update request
to the data provider asking
for a specific type of data.
The provider builds a
complication data object
of that type with
the required fields
and sends it back to Wear.
Android Wear then forwards
that onto the watch face,
which can then include
it when it renders.
Android Wear also
provides the UI
that allows users
to choose providers
for each complication.
And we'll talk
about that in a bit.
But now let's take
a look at what you
need to do to add
complications to a watch face.
So first of all,
you need to decide
how many complications
to include
and what types to
support in each one.
So, for this example,
let's say you
want to include a small round
complication on the right.
Now in that space we
could support short text.
We could also support icon.
And there's also enough space
there to show a ranged value.
Now in that space we
could, if we wanted,
support small image as well.
But let's say for this
example that we don't want to.
Now let's say we
also want to include
a complication at the bottom.
This one could support the
same types as the first one.
But there's also enough
space to make this one wider.
So it could support
the long text type.
Note that we consider this
to be the same complication.
Even though it's a different
shape, depending on the type.
So to summarizes, these
are the types supported
by each of those complications.
One more thing, you need
to give each complication
a numerical ID so that you can
refer to it with the system.
That's chosen by the watch face.
We call it the watch
face complication ID,
and it can be any integer.
OK, so next you need
a way for the user
to choose providers
for each complication.
As I mentioned
earlier, Android Wear
provides the UI to
choose a provider
for a particular complication.
But the rest of the
UI is up to you.
So what we're showing
here on the slide
is a basic list that could be
part of the watch faces config
activity.
It's the watch
face's own settings.
So this screen is not
provided by the system.
So when the user taps
on item in this list,
the watch face needs to launch
that system provider chooser.
Let's look at some code.
So, in order to do that, you
use this support library method
to get hold of an intent.
That's
createProviderChooserIntent.
You pass in the watch
face component name.
That's the package and class
name of your watch face.
That's just how you refer to
your watch face to the system.
And you also pass in the
watch face complication
ID for the complication
that is being configured.
So that's the number
we chose earlier.
You then pass in the types
supported by that complication.
In this list, the
order doesn't matter.
You list them in
order of preference,
with the most
preferred coming first.
In this example, we've put
ranged value at the top.
That's because that
type conveys the most
information to the user.
So that's often a good choice.
And that's a good way
to think about this.
OK.
So then when you
have the intent,
you call
startActivityforResult to show
the system provide chooser.
So, when the user taps
on an item in this list,
the system provider
choose is shown.
Now when the user chooses
a provider in this UI,
it gets setup automatically.
You don't need to
do anything else.
OK, so to show the data,
what you need to do
is tell the system
that your watch
face is ready to receive it.
So let's move into
the watch face service
itself, specifically the engine.
So what you need to do is
call setActiveComplications,
and pass in the watch
face complication
IDs for the complications
that are ready.
Here we're showing in
onCreate of the engine.
That's usually a
good place to do it.
But you can call this
method from elsewhere.
For example, if the active
complications change.
Once you've done that, you will
start to receive data in calls
to the on complication
data update method.
The data will come with the
watch face complication ID
that it relates to.
Now, you'll only receive
data when it changes.
So you'll have to hold onto
the complication data object.
And any images, such as icons,
should be loaded asynchronously
and be sure to catch them.
Now once you've got the
data, it's up to you
how to incorporate it
into your watch face.
But before rendering
it, you need
to check if the data
is still active.
Some complication data is only
valid until a certain time.
So for example, it might be
for a next event complication.
And then the piece of
data will only be relevant
up until the end of that event.
You check it using
this method, the
is active method on
the complication data.
So you just pass
in the current time
when you're drawing a
frame to see if you still
need to draw that data.
There's one other
thing you should do,
which is to check to see if
complications are tapped on.
You do this using the
interactive watch face's APIs
that we announced last year.
So that is by implementing
onTap command.
If a complication is
tapped on, then you
need to check the complication
data to see if it specifies
a tap action pending intent.
If there is one, you need
to fire that intent when
the computation is tapped on.
This allows deep linking
from the complication
straight into a
relevant activity.
OK, so that's how
to add complications
to your watch face.
One important tip that goes
for watch phase development
in general, but particularly
for complications,
is minimize the work you
do in every draw call,
especially if you're drawing
more than once a second.
Avoid object creation in
On Draw wherever possible.
As that can lead to a lot of
garbage collection and, hence,
poor performance.
OK, so now let's take a look
at how to build a complication
data provider.
A data provider is a service.
And to create one, you need to
extend complication provider
service from the
support library.
This class has one abstract
method that you must implement.
That is On Complication Updates.
This method is called whenever
the system wants data from you.
So it will be called
when a complication using
your provider is activated.
By which I mean, when
the watch face calls
Set Active Complications.
And it will also be called
when your provider is
chosen for a complication
that's already active.
It can also be called
with a certain frequency,
such as every hour, if
that's what you want.
And it's also possible
to trigger updates
if you need a push style.
For example, if you
have a messaging app,
and you want to update a
complication when a message
arrives, you could do this.
If you want more information
on that then check out
the provider update request
class in the previous support
library.
OK, so let's take a look
at an example of how you
might implement this method.
So you'll see that one of
the parameters is the type.
That's the complication
type that's required.
And the first thing we're
going to do is check that.
Now in this example, we're only
going to support short text.
In a real world example
you would probably
support more than one type.
So first thing now is we start
building a complication data
object of that type,
type short text.
And now we're setting
the short text
field, which is the required
field for this type.
And we do it assessing it
to a simple string, "hello."
You'll notice that it's wrapped
here is a complication text
object.
All of the set methods for
text in complication data
take one of these
complication text objects.
It can just be a wrapper for
simple string or char sequence.
It can also be used
for other things.
And we'll talk about
that a bit later.
OK, so we're also going
to specify an icon.
That's an optional
field for short text.
All of the image set methods
for complication data
use the icon class from
the Android framework.
That allows it to
be either a wrapper
for a resource from
your application,
a drawable resource.
Or it could also be a bitmap.
However, as I mentioned
earlier, the icon field images
should always be tintable.
They should be single color
with a transparent background.
And we strongly recommend you
use vector drawables for this.
That's because the watch
face could draw the icon
at different sizes.
And using a vector will
allow it to resize cleanly.
OK, so that completes
the complication data
object for this example.
All you need to do next is
send that data to the system.
And you do that using
the complication manager
object, which is passed
in as a parameter
to on complication update.
OK, there are two other
methods that you can optionally
implement.
They are,
onComplicationActivated
onComplicationDeactivate.
Complications are activated when
the watch face calls Set Active
Complications.
And they are deactivated
either by another call
to Set Active Complications
with different IDs
or when the user
changes watch face.
Now, as a service,
your provider has
to be declared in the manifest.
And that's also where you use
metadata to declare things
like what types you can
support and what update period
you would like, if any.
Here, with the supported types,
the order does not matter.
And that's because, as
I mentioned earlier,
the watch face gets to decide
the order of preference
for any particular complication.
Now for the update period, be
aware that the update period
is not guaranteed.
We do apply a minimum.
The system applies a minimum.
So you should think
in terms of minutes
or longer, not seconds,
particularly in ambient mode
or when the device
isn't being worn,
update requests might
come less frequently.
Try to make the update period as
long as is reasonably possible.
Getting updates too often
could impact battery life.
If your provider doesn't
need regular updates at all,
then you can just
set this to zero.
And then you won't get any
calls beyond the initial one.
Now one example
where you might think
you want to update
every minute is
where you are displaying
something related
to the time on the watch face.
So here you can see
two complications where
the text changes every minute.
We've got a world clock and
the time to my next event.
But it would be wasteful to wake
up the provider every minute.
And there's no guarantee
that the update request
would come in at the point
where the minute changes.
Even the date complication
shouldn't need to update.
Even though it would
only be once a day,
there's no guarantee
the update will
come at the stroke of midnight.
So it would be showing incorrect
data at certain times of day.
So instead, the API allows you
to use time dependent text.
For text that represents
the current time,
we have time format text.
And for text that represents the
time to or from a given time,
use the time difference text.
Let's take a look at an example.
So let's say that we're
building a complication showing
the time to my next meeting.
And we're using the
short text type.
So I'm building the complication
data of type short text.
We saw earlier that
set short text takes
a complication text object.
And that's so that here we
can pass in a different kind
of complication text object.
So we're going to
use Time Difference
Builder to create one.
So passing into the
builder, we need
to set the reference period.
That is the time that
the text relates to.
So in this case it's the
time of my next event.
Let's say that's from
4:00 PM until 5:00 PM.
In that case,
start time here Is.
4:00 PM.
End time here is 5:00 PM.
Now we add a style.
So this just determines
how the text is formatted,
is displayed.
In this case we're
using short joule unit.
That means, for
example, if the time
difference was five hours and 15
minutes, it would show 5H 15M.
That completes the
time difference text.
So we call Build.
There's one more thing.
As I mentioned earlier,
complication data
can cease to be valid
after a certain time.
And that is the case here.
And it's particularly
important here
because the time difference
text is the time to the event,
but it's also the
time since the event.
So if it were 10
minutes after my event,
then the complication might show
10M, which is not what we want.
So we have to set an end
time so that it shows nothing
after the event.
OK, so that completes
the complication data.
So we just call Build.
Let's see what that would
look like on the watch face.
So, the event is at 4:00 PM.
One hour and 45 minutes
before, we would see this.
At 3:45 PM, we would see this.
So although it's
the short joule unit
style, when it's only minutes,
we only show the minutes.
We never show seconds
in this style.
During the event,
we would show this.
So the time difference text
actually shows the text now.
These strings, all
of these strings
are localized according to
the locale of the device.
After the event we see nothing.
Because we set the end time.
So for more details of the
types and styles of time
dependent text, check out
the complication text class
in the wearable support preview.
OK, so that's the Complications
API for both data providers
and for watch faces.
We're really excited to see
how you all make use of it.
TONY FERREIRA: Thanks.
So if you like what
you've heard here today,
and you'd like to
try it out, you can.
Just go to g.co/wearpreview.
You can find out about how to
get the Preview SDK, device
images, and more information
about the APIs we're launching.
The dev preview also
includes this watch face.
It's called elements.
And it supports a variety
of complication types.
So you can test any data
providers you build.
The preview does include a few
providers, like battery level,
world clock, and date.
You can use these to test the
complications on your watch
face.
Here is a list of the
Android Wear sessions
that were on today at
I/O. And don't worry
if you've missed any of
them, because they're
all be on YouTube soon.
OLIN LAN: So if you'd like to
have a go at creating a watch
face with complications or
building a data provider,
do check out the code labs.
You can do them here
at I/O. Or you can go
to g.co/codelabs/io16/wear.
We'd also love to hear any
feedback you have on the API.
So if you find any bugs, or
if you have any suggestions
or questions, please go
to g.co/wearpreviewbug.
And finally, if you'd like to
discuss the Complications API
or anything else about Android
Wear with other developers,
go on to Android Wear
developers G+ Community
at g.co/androidweardev.
OK, thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]